Okay.
So presumably the reason we've got into
this situation,
this mindset you might call us,
right?
I want to say we,
I mean the culture certainly on the left
is this remarkable transformation that's
taking place in the potential and
possibilities that women have enjoyed
over the last 40 years when they turned
out to be,
it seems much more plastic and capable
and having a great deal more talents and
potentiality is that we used to think in
the 1950s and this extraordinary
liberation that's happened and it has
happened on questions as has seems to
have led us to the point of view that
there is a kind of infinite malleability
going well,
but you can see how the argument would
have got there.
Well it's,
I would say it's partly about,
it's certainly partly post birth control
confusion,
right?
Because with the invention of the birth
control pill,
you basically have a new female or
because there's never been a female in
the history of life that have voluntary
control over her reproductive
capability.
And now that's possible.
MMM.
So then the question arises,
well,
what is this new creature life?
And one answer is she's like any way she
wants to be.
And then if you ally that as well with
the Marxist sharp turn up,
which is a social construction as
doctrine that the state constructs the
individual and should do so then you get
a double whammy.
And that,
so some of it's understandable because
we are still trying to figure out the
parameters of female behavior once
femininity is unlocked from involuntary
reproductions and also the birth control
can about,
I've pretty much the same time,
it says it quite an uptick in economic.
So there was presumably a great deal,
well possibility there is a great deal
of possibility because it's quite clear
that women are as intelligent as men for
example.
Although the variability might differ as
we discussed and there was
conscientiousness man and so,
and there is created as men.
So although they may not be as creative
as old man's,
so that remains to be seen,
but we'll see how that plays out.
So it's not surprising that there's a
lot of upheaval in the relationships
between men and women because the bird
is,
you know,
when humanity looks back on the 20th
century,
they're going to identify three dramatic
revolutions.
One is going to be,
let's say the last half of the 20th
century.
One is going to be the transistor,
the other is going to be the hydrogen
bomb,
and the third is going to be the birth
control pill.
And they're all of of of revolutionary
significance.
It's even more complex than that because
it turns out that women on the birth
control pill,
like feminine men better than masculine
men.
So the preference actually shifts when
their own,
because of some hormonal change.
Yeah.
So if you track women across their
menstrual cycle when they're not on the
tails,
so what you do is you show them
photographs of men,
the same manny,
but all you do is vary his jaw width,
which you can do.
We're on a continuum with the computer.
Now John With is associated with
testosterone.
So larger job guys have higher levels of
testosterone and women prefer the larger
job guy when they're ovulating.
And the smaller John's guy,
when they're gifted from reproduction
possibility.
And,
and so you see,
women might want a monster to mate with
and uh,
uh,
pell to raise children with.
And I think in,
in the beauty and the beast story,
which I think is in some ways the
central female myth,
there's an attempt to bridge the gap
because what the woman does is find a
monster and payment,
but you want your man to be tame enough
so he doesn't eat your children,
but you want them to be rough enough so
that your son has a fighting chance in
the mating hierarchy.
And so that you have someone tough and
aggressive is potentially able to
protect you around.
And there's a lot of sexual
attractiveness.
I'm not park.
And now element.